У німецькому Бонні та швейцарському Берні
вперше показують цю ціну колекцію витворів мистецтва.
Серед експонатів – картини німецьких художників
Ернста Людвіґа Кірхнера,
Макса Бекманна, Отто Дікса
і російського митця Василя Кандинського.
Роботи, представлені на виставці,
це лише частина зі знайдених творів
в одній з мюнхенських квартир в 2012 році.
До цього десятки років їх ніхто не бачив.
Окрім однієї людини - Корнеліуса Ґурлітта.
Під час обшуку його квартири правоохоронці виявили
близько півтори тисячі витворів мистецтва.
Іншу частину експонатів знайшли
в резиденції Ґурлітта в Зальцбурзі.
Корнеліус був одинаком, уособлював себе
більше з мистецтвом, ніж з людьми.
Колекцію зібрав батько Ґурлітта – Гільдербранд.
Він співпрацював з нацистами, будучи арт-дилером
так званого в той час "виродженого сучасного мистецтва".
Після поразки нацистів, йому вдалося переконати союзників,
що картини згоріли в зруйнованому Дрездені.
Натомість Ґурлітт переховував їх, передаючи в спадок.
Нині лише шість робіт ідентифіковані як "викрадені нацистами
твори мистецтва". Ви можете сказати:
шість робіт – це не так багато.
Але я б сказав, це надто багато. Це шість картин,
за якими криються людські долі.
Корнеліус Ґурлітт помер у 2014 році
і всю свою колекцію заповів Художньому музею Берна,
якого шокував такий подарунок.
Більшість цих робіт були конфісковані нацистами з музеїв,
деякі - у єврейських родин.  Близько півтисячі творів мистецтва
швейцарський музей залишив Німеччині для досліджень.
Виставка в Бонні зосереджена на експонатах,
викрадених у жертв нациського режиму,
та на роботах, чиїх власників ще не встановили.
Віднайти походження творів через 70 років
після викрадення у ті трагічні часи - не так просто.